I spent the last two months rereading
and analyzing every one piece chapter
and found Six Theories that will
absolutely blow your mind for example
there is this one theory about
Blackbeard's laugh that left me
completely stunned you probably noticed
that one piece is full of weird laughs
but did you ever notice that some of the
characters laughs correspond with the
devil fruit they ate take white beards
Coronas or streusen's laughs for example
they all laugh with the first letters of
their fruit now with that said did you
ever notice how teach laughs teacher's
laugh is
which may seem unimportant initially but
if this theory is right it may be a key
to one of the biggest one-piece
Mysteries there is a mythical creature
called baezi also known as Haku taku in
Japan now if you take those names first
and last words you get teachers laughs
so it is possible that teach already ate
his third devil fruit you probably think
this is just a stupid coincidence but
bear with me it gets crazy from here
baize is mythical creature usually
portrayed as a tiger sheep or lion with
three heads or three eyes on its side
the interesting thing about this is that
teach's flag also has three heads and
the number three is very emphasized in
teacher's appearance also his
personality usually varies throughout
the show as sometimes he acts like a
coward sometimes he is cautious and
sometimes overconfident this would also
align perfectly with the Animals by Z is
representing sheep for his cowardice
lion for his overconfidence and tiger
for his calm and cautious personality
what's more did you ever take a good
look at shank's scar how did teach even
give it to him many fans speculate the
teach used his claw weapon to do this
but I don't think that's true if you
look at teach's weapon you'll notice
that it has four blades while shank's
star only has three lines based on this
it's likely that Blackbeard transformed
into his by Z form and surprise Shanks
which allowed him to scar him with his
claws also baizy literally translates to
White Marsh which could hint towards
Whitebeard and Marshall I'll give this
Theory 4 out of 10 chances of happening
but in the later parts of the video I'll
be revealing some theories that have a 9
out of 10 probability of happening now
that you understand how crazy this video
is going to be let me tell you this
insane theory about emu and the one
piece world that might just turn out to
be true did it ever seem odd that one
piece world is nothing but Islands did
it ever seem strange that there are a
lot of structures built underwater from
sunken cities and underground prisons to
underground islands and giant Gates heck
there is even this big subscribe button
at the bottom of the sea that's just
waiting to be clicked anyway it's almost
like an entirely different world existed
and was flooded at some point right well
that is exactly where this next Theory
comes in in chapter 908 one of the
gorose said the balance of the world
can't be maintained forever it seems
like there is a need for a great
cleansing so what exactly did he mean by
this and could it be connected to the
underwater structures we mentioned
earlier well firstly it's important to
mention that Oda takes a lot of
references from real world religions
especially Christianity this can be
observed on multiple occasions like Kuma
carrying a Bible mihawk marrying a
necklace with a cross devil fruits
Angels living in the sky you get the
point so what if this great cleansing is
also inspired by Christianity and refers
to the story of Noah's Ark where God
flooded the Earth after researching this
theory for quite some time I found some
evidence to prove this as you already
know emu and the celestial dragons live
on the top of the red line in the city
of Marisha now it's really interesting
that they chose that specific location
especially because it's the highest
point in the one piece world and would
make completely safe from the flood it's
also an interesting parallel that
Celestial dragons are referred to as
Gods which makes it even more fitting
that they fled the one-piece world the
same as the god did in Noah's story this
Theory would also explain why there are
only islands in this world you see if
the world was really flooded that would
make only the highest points above the
sea visible while everything else would
sink this phenomenon was perfectly
explained during the long-ring long land
Arc where the path connecting small
Islands wasn't visible because it was
underwater but how would the Goro say
even do something like this well I think
that's where emu comes in I don't know
how many of you noticed but emu's name
in Reverse spells the word Umi and the
word Umi means see in Japanese it's too
early to say but emu could have some
kind of power to control the sea to some
extent or raise sea levels anyway we'll
need to wait a bit more till Oda reveals
what exactly it is for now I'll give
this one a score of 5 out of 10. ah
bounties the completely made up numbers
that government gives to pirates wait a
second are they really random well what
if I tell you that these these bounties
are actually carefully crafted and have
a meaning behind them and that we can
use this information to determine what
Luffy's final Bounty will be at the end
of the show okay so if you take a closer
look at some of the last numbers of each
Bounty you'll notice that they actually
have a meaning in Japanese okay you
maybe won't notice that since you are
probably not from Japan so let me
explain whitebeard's last numbers are
four and six and if we take the first
syllable of those numbers which are she
and Ro you'll get the word Shiro which
literally means white in Japanese if we
do the same with kaido's last number
which is 110 we'll get the word jakugu
which translates to Beast or 100 Beasts
for big mom the word is Haha which
translates to mother and you may wonder
how does this help us determine Luffy's
final Bounty you see there is one
combination of numbers that would fit
perfectly for Luffy and those numbers
are five six five six which would make
his final Bounty 5 billion 656 million
bellies why is this number so perfect
for Luffy firstly it would put him right
above the previous pirate king Goldie
Roger which all all of us are expecting
to eventually happen in the series
secondly numbers 5656 literally spell
the words gomugomu which is the name of
Luffy's devil fruit seriously you can't
find a more fitting Bounty than this it
deserves at least a 5 out of 10 score
and if you thought this one was crazy
we'll start covering the top three
theories on this list and these ones
will quite literally blow you away did
you ever notice that the song [ __ ] sake
the one that Brook loves to sing
actually has some really interesting
connections to laughtail and might tell
us exactly where it is you probably
think I am crazy for using a song to
locate the final Island but when you
think about it it actually makes a lot
of sense before we get into how exactly
Luffy and the crew will get to the laugh
tale let's first explain why the
information so major would be hidden in
the ordinary Pirate song well it's
important to remember that Joy boy lived
during the void century and we all know
how everything about that period of time
was erased from the history so wouldn't
it be a genius if joyboy had concealed
these important instructions into a
cheerful song in an attempt to secure
really pass it on yes it would and I
think that's exactly what he did all
right but what about this song is so
important well let's take a closer look
at some of the song's lines and try
deciphering them firstly it's emphasized
multiple times throughout the song that
the crew is delivering being sake so
what is it it must be important well in
the show sake is usually something that
connects people's stories and brings
them closer together we can observe this
when Sabo Ace and Luffy become brothers
when they drink Sake so could the sake
in the song refer to connecting the
entire world's story and delivering the
knowledge of all pony glyphs I think so
and this is further confirmed by Roger
when he left the message near The Sky
Islands poneglyph saying that he will
guide that text to the ends of the Earth
since the laughtail is the final Island
at the end of the sea this fits
perfectly in the next few lines some
kind of storm is described that will try
to stop the crew from coming near the
island and they'll have to beat up on
the drums and hold on until the morning
sun rises with the recent manga chapters
this is also really fitting as Luffy's
heart and dear fifth beats in the Rhythm
the drums of Liberation in my opinion
he'll probably need to transform into
this form and fend off some kind of
threat that will try to stop him maybe a
real storm or possibly a Villain Like
Blackbeard the song finishes with the
line never ending ever wandering our
funny traveling tale and what's
interesting about this is that the
phrase are funny traveling tale is
spelled exactly the same in Japanese as
the laugh tale which just further proves
that there is a real connection between
the song and the island I'll easily give
this one 6 out of 10 but this next one
about okiji and Blackbeard is so good
that it actually has an eight out of of
10 probability of happening although he
was a marine kuzong was the only one
among the Admirals who followed his own
sense of justice and therefore we can
all agree that joining Blackbeard
Pirates is going against everything he
stands for there must be a reason for it
right yes I believe kuzan is actually a
spy sent to keep an eye on Blackbeard by
the Revolutionary Army and there are a
few things that confirm this in episode
625 after akiji saved smoker he tells
him that there are certain things he can
do now since he is not a part of the
Marines anymore and that the grass is
always greener on the other side this
could imply that he joined some other
organization furthermore during the
reverie Arc it was revealed that the
revolutionaries escaped boltigo just in
time before Blackbeard arrived and
destroyed the island since akiji is a
crew member now he probably knew that
Blackbeard was going to attack and could
have tipped off Dragon about his plans
if you still don't believe this there is
one more thing that may persuade you for
unknown reasons Blackbeard's 10 captains
are called Titanic commanders this seems
pretty irrelevant Until you realize that
the thing that sank the actual real
world Titanic was an iceberg and since
akiji is literally an Iceman this
perfectly symbolizes that he may betray
them in the future eight out of ten is a
fair score for this Theory but let's
dial the crazy up to the Max and cover
the wildest theory on the list with a
score of 9 out of 10 that states that
Rayleigh is mihawk's father okay that's
a pretty weird statement but there is
actually a lot of evidence by this may
be true firstly let's start with the
similarities between the two both of
them use a sword in battle mihawk is the
strongest swordsman now while Rayleigh
was most likely the strongest swordsman
in his time Oda has also hinted at the
connection between the two and how they
dress if you look closely you'll notice
that mihawk and younger Rayleigh have a
really similar pattern on their clothing
now we can easily pass all of these as
coincidences but let me tell you one
more thing first I also believe
shakuyaku is mihawk's Mother think about
it if Rayleigh ever had a child it would
most likely be with her but that's not
the only reason if you put shakyan
mihawk next to each other they have some
visible similarities the most obvious
one being their spiky hair and lastly
mihawk was seen wearing a shirt with
peonies during Roger's execution why
does this matter well if you translate
shaki's full name from Japanese to
English you'll get wait for it peonies I
think this one just has to be true and
it would be really cool to see Rayleigh
and mihawk fighting together at some
point if you like these theories and
want to hear more you can click on this
video where I explained 12 more insane
one-piece theories you definitely didn't
know